mettez-vous tout d'abord au nom de la
commission dans son ensemble
d'exprimer notre solidarité notre
soutien à ophélie meunier qui a fait
l'objet de menaces de mort et qui est
sous protection policière depuis un
reportage diffusé sur m6
pour nous tous ici évidemment toute
atteinte à la liberté d'expression de
travail d'un journaliste est quelque
chose d'inacceptable et c'est donc
naturellement mais avec force que nous
lui apportons notre sous une solidarité
et notre soutien
mais c'est le rapporteur mais mes chers
collègues nous allons reprendre nos
travaux de la commune de notre
commission denquête en recevant ce jour
monsieur patrick drahi je rappelle que
cette commission denquête a été
constitué à la demande de groupes
socialistes écologistes et républicains
et à pourra porter david assouline qui
est à mes côtés
monsieur patrick drahi nous vous
remercions d'avoir pu vous rendre
rapidement disponible pour les travaux
de notre commission denquête
avec quelques autres vous faites partie
de ces grands capitaines d'industrie qui
ont choisi d'investir dans les médias
votre groupe altis possède en effet
l'opérateur sfr et plusieurs câblo
opérateur dans de nombreux pays mais
vous êtes également et c'est ce qui
motive votre présence aujourd'hui devant
nous un acteur majeur des médias via
altis médias votre groupe allie les
réseaux et les contenus cette
diversification remonte à 2015 quand
vous avez racheté nextradiotv a à la
veille qu'il avait fondée lui-même en
2000 le groupe est aujourd'hui le
troisième opérateur privé en france avec
les marques bfm première chaîne
d'informations en continu et rmc par
ailleurs en 2014 vous entré au capital
du journal libération en 2020 vous
annoncer avoir épuré les dettes du
quotidien et le placer sous l'autorité
d'une fondation régis par un fonds de
dotation afin de garantir son
indépendance et sa pérennité vous êtes
donc aujourd'hui l'un des plus grands
acteurs des médias en france ce qui
suscite bien entendu une attention
médiatique et politique toute
particulière la commission est donc
heureuse de vous entendre et désireuse
de vous entendre d'autant plus que votre
dernier passage au sénat remonte à 2007
2016 pardon au sujet des origines et des
raisons de votre engagement dans les
médias nous avons donc un certain nombre
de questions à vous poser
sur la stratégie de votre groupe dans
les domaines des médias sur la relation
de l'actionner vous êtes avec les médias
qui sont dans votre groupe et de manière
plus large
l'analyse que vous faites de l'évolution
des médias en france je vous propose
l'organisation suivante qui est commune
à toutes les auditions que nous venons
ici je vais vous laisser la parole pour
dix minutes 10 minutes pas plus tout
simplement pour permettre un dialogue et
des échanges avec vous à travers des des
questions et des réponses ce sera le
rapporteur david assouline qui entamera
les la série des questions je vous
rappelle que cette audition est diffusée
en direct sur le site internet du sénat
et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié enfin je rappelle pour la
forme qu un faux témoignage devant notre
commission denquête seraient passibles
des peines prévues aux articles 400
34-13 14 et 15 du code pénal je vous
précise également qui vous appartient le
cas échéant d'indiquer vos éventuels
liens d'intérêts ou conflits d'intérêts
en relation avec l'objet de la
commission denquête
je vais vous inviter monsieur draghi a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure merci et
je vous donne la parole donc pour dix
minutes je vous précise que certains de
nos collègues qui sont ici en présentiel
et d'autres qui sont également derrière
leur écran
merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs merci beaucoup de de me
recevoir ce que je parle assez fort est
ce que les micros
alors je peux avancer le micro je peux
parler plus fort est-ce que c'est mieux
et je peux aussi enlevé le masque je
suis triple vacciner je dois voir le
record du monde et des anticorps parce
que troisième vaccin
voilà moi j'aime ça fait tester les
anticorps être avant le troisième vaccin
je trouve ça inutile mais bon
parfait bon voilà alors c'est mieux là
je m'entendais voilà alors écoutez merci
beaucoup de me recevoir j'étais
effectivement
parmi vous dans l'eau lors d'une autre
commission je crois que c'était en juin
2016 et si vous le permettez je veux
refaire le point de ce qui s'est passé
dans mon groupe pour vous donner un
petit une petite mise à jour entre je
pars faire l'historique des 20 dernières
années mais entre 2016 quand je suis
venu la dernière fois et aujourd'hui
donc en 2016
ça faisait un peu à peu près un an et
quelques mois que j'avais racheté sfr et
je venais de rentrer au capital je
n'avais pas racheter comme vous le
mentionnez tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
racheter encore bfm à la veile j'étais
minoritaire au capital de bfm
j'avais 49% du capital et j'ai complété
ce rachat en 2018 si je ne m'abuse en
tout cas après 2017
sur la partie générale de mon groupe à
l'époque
nous faisions environ 20 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires et nous ferons cette
année à peu près 50
sur la partie française
sfr était une entreprise en déclin quand
je les ai racheté déclin de chiffre
d'affaires
déclin d'abonnés
image très très mauvaise et donc nous
nous sommes employés au cours des
premières années et toujours investir
massivement j'avais pris un engagement
lors du rachat des ses fers dans les
négociations avec l'état plusieurs
engagements
de maintenir assez faire en france de
mettre un président français est un
engagement industriel qui était
notamment d'amplifier la couverture 4g
et aussi de couvrir alors 22 millions de
foyers français c'était facile à retenir
d'ici 2022
alors tous ces engagements ont été tenus
président français bon grégory rabut
elle est ici dans la pièce d'ailleurs un
jeune président français la société
toujours en france la couverture 4g et a
aujourd'hui alors que nous étions
derniers de la classe quand j'ai repris
sfr on est à 99,9 pour cent vous savez
que les opérateurs ont pris un
engagement vis-à-vis de l'état de
couvrir 100% du territoire ce qui sera
le seul pays d'europe voire du monde à
avoir une couverture à 100%
sur le mobile
nous étions derniers en 4g vous avez
sans doute vu les rapports récents
l'arcep nous sommes premiers ex-aequo en
5 g aujourd'hui et sur la fibre optique
nous n'avons pas tenu notre engagement
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas fait
22 millions de prises pour 2022 mais
nous serons plutôt vers 30 d'ici la fin
de l'année donc on a fait au delà de ce
qui était prévu et pourquoi parce que
durant toute cette période contrairement
à la période précédente nous n'avons pas
pris un euro dividendes et nous avons
consacré l'intégralité
du des ressources financières de
l'entreprise à investir quand j'ai pris
sfr l'investissement annuel était de
l'ordre d'un milliard et demi par an et
demi heure 6 pour être précis il est
aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 3 milliards
d'euros par an dans la 5g dans la fibre
dans les couvertures 4g dans les
équipements des clients dans
l'amélioration des services etc etc nous
sommes passés d'une situation le chiffre
d'affaires décroît ces 2 5% et
aujourd'hui il est en croissance
annuelle de 5% nous sommes revenus un
chiffre d'affaires super avant celui de
celui des c'est faire avant l'entrée du
4e opérateur est là où nous perdions
environ un million de clients par an
aujourd'hui nous en gagnons environ un
million par an donc non seulement on est
revenus là où nous étions meinau au
dessus de là où nous étions
petites évolutions capitalistiques dans
mon groupe quand je suis venu vous voir
en 2016 en juin 2016 je détenais environ
60% du capital de mon entreprise
jean détient aujourd'hui 100%
donc ça a le mérite d'être simple au
niveau des conseils d'administration et
c'est 100% familiales ceci en
partenariat avec certains de mes
collaborateurs qui ont une participation
à mes côtés
vous vous inquiétez à l'époque de mon
niveau de dette qui était de l'ordre de
50 milliards la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'il est toujours de 50 milliards mais
pour un chiffre d'affaires qui a
quasiment doublé donc une performance
qui est remarquable et j'emprunte
aujourd'hui sur les marchés après deux
fois moins cher de ce qu'il ya de didier
d'il ya cinq ans quel résultat alors
même que des taux d'intérêt sont en
train de remonter comme vous le savez
est ce qu est le résultat des
performances pas que financière mais
opérationnel et de la confiance qui a
été retrouvée auprès des investisseurs
sur la partie alors des choses nouvelles
dans mon groupe au delà des ces quelques
chiffres que je vais me donner nous
sommes devenus le premier actionnaire de
british telecom je crois que ça peut
être une fierté pour l'industrie
française pour un groupe que j'ai
démarré à châteaurenard dans les
bouches-du-rhône petite ville de
quelques milliers d'habitants se
retrouvaient première actionnaire du
premier opérateur européen même si
l'angleterre est sortie de l'europe
politique est fait pour partie de
l'europe géographique
nous avons sur la partie média au delà
des marques très connues
je détiens aujourd'hui la licorne la
plus performante du marché français qui
s'appelle ty ce qu est une société à
l'origine créé par un français savoyard
précisément qui est le numéro un mondial
de la vidéo publicitaire en ligne c'est
à dire que quand vous allez
sur par exemple le site de quelques
journaux quelque journal que ce soit en
france en angleterre aux états unis
pourrait un peu partout dans le monde
vous défilez un article vous voyez par
moments des vidéos qui apparaissent de
publicité nous sommes numéro un mondial
dans ce secteur et c'est une entreprise
aujourd'hui à titre de comparaison qui
est huit fois plus grandes en termes de
volumes de chiffre d'affaires que bfm
même si vous n'en avez sans doute jamais
entendu parler puisque bfm est devenu
une marque extrêmement connue en france
mais pour vous donner la mesure des
dimensions des différents outils sur la
partie média qui nous intéresse au jour
et plus particulièrement
je suis effectivement j'ai commencé mon
aventure dans les médias en france
non pas en 2016 quand je suis entré au
capital de bfm n'ont pas non plus en
2014 quand j'ai racheté
libération mais en 1995 à marne la
vallée pour ceux qui étaient encore là
en lançant canal coquelicot petite
chaîne locale du réseau câblé vous
souvenez à l'époque du plan câble chaque
grande ville de france avait lancé une
chaîne d'information locale c'est un
fiasco notoire d'ailleurs elles ont
pratiquement toutes disparu et moi
modestement avec les autorités
administratrice du du val maubuée nous
avions lancé une petite chaîne canal
coquelicot qui fonctionne toujours
puisqu'elle avait un budget raisonnable
et qui traitait de l'information locale
alors cette expérience des chaînes
locales m'a conduit progressivement à
m'intéresser aux médias et ma première
grande aventure dans les médias c'est en
2005 quand j'ai racheté les droits du
football de 2e division en france
puisque à ce moment là se reconstituer
le la fusion entre les deux plate forme
satellitaire si vous vous souvenez entre
tps d'une part et canalsat est donc
cette fusion entraîné un manque de
concurrence au niveau des rachats de
droit et donc moi je me suis faufilé
dans une petite roue où j'ai pu racheter
les droits de la ligue 2 à pas cher
puisqu'il avait qu'un seul acheteur donc
c'est l'acheteur qui faisait le prix et
le vendeur a préféré me confier des
droits que les vendre à l'acheteur de
l'époque c'est comme ça que j'ai démarré
dans le sport en lançant quelque chose
alors qu'on n'était pas très créatif au
niveau de la marque on avait appelé ça
ma chaîne sport c'est pas moi qui la
gérait c'était le gars qui s'en occupe
et donc il trouvait que c'était sa
chaîne il avait dit ma chaîne sport
grande réussite distribué par toutes les
plateformes partout en europe partout en
afrique et puis de fil en aiguille on
s'est intéressé de plus en plus à
investir dans les médias n'ont pas je
sais que voudront voix à voir la
question les questions tout à l'heure
sur l'influencé de cet arabe davantage
en tant qu aventure économique en
prolongement de nos activités parce
qu'en réalité qu'est ce qu'on apporte
par le câble ou par la fibre optique on
apporte la lumière on apporte la
civilisation on apporte les
éclaircissements sur tout ce qui se
passe on apporte du contenu avant tout
et du service à nos clients donc il a
assez logique pour un opérateur de
distribution
deux d'être impliqué dans la partie
contenu ensuite bien évidemment la
partie la plus connue de mon groupe en
france sur la partie média c'est bien
évidemment le groupe dont vous
mentionnez on vous parlait est à l'heure
bfm et rmc depuis que je suis rentré au
capital de ce groupe un grand
développement s'est mise en place par le
nouveau le développement des chaînes
locales on a lancé je vous l'annoncé
d'ailleurs au sénat en 2016 que nous
allions lancé bfm paris depuis nous
avons lancé bfm lyon bfm lille bfm grand
littoral
bfm côte d'azur vous sous et bfm dc
c'est une petite chaîne régionale dans
le 04 et le 05 qui s'appelait dix sites
chaîne tv10 si donc on a repris cette
chaîne dont la renommée bfm d'ici qui
couvre deux départements
nous venons d'avoir l'autorisation je
crois à hier où avant-hier pour la
reprise d'une chaîne de télévision
locale en normandie qu'on va renommer
bfm normandie j'imagine arthur d'avant
ici là-bas donc arthur quel patron de du
groupe média en france est aussi le
directeur du le secrétaire général de
sfr secrétaire général chez nous ça veut
dire
communication relations avec les
institutions et toute la réglementation
c'est à ce titre qu'il est là à double
double casquette relations avec les
institutions je suis dans une
institution et m'accompagne voulez
parler de médias il m'accompagne
maintenant le grand patron des fmcc lui
est l'actionnaire c'est moi être très
clairement
j'ai des médias également dehors de
france j'ai une chaîne d'information
produite en partie au moyen-orient à tel
aviv en partie à paris en partie à new
york qui diffuse à l'échelon
international qui s'appelle i 24 il 24
news donc chaîne d'information
internationale qui se focalise sur le
moyen-orient avec trois rédactions en
trois langues une en français une en
anglais et une en arabe
des chaînes d'information sur la région
de new york je n'ai pas créé mais que
j'ai trouvé dans le temps au sein du
réseau câblé de new york que je possède
qui s'appelle news twelve qui est un
grande réussite qu'est la première
chaîne d'information locale de la région
de new york alors pas dans manhattan aux
alentours de manhattan et vous demander
de conclure pourrait rester dans
quelques secondes mais voilà sinon on va
voilà j'ai écouté j'ai fini en réalité
je suis président j'ai fini c'était pour
vous donner une petit tour d'horizon des
évolutions depuis deux plaies dernière
fois que je suis venu maintenant je suis
à votre disposition merci monsieur
draghi les première question vous est
posée par david assouline notre
rapporteur
bonsoir monsieur dry alors l'objet de
notre commission denquête c'est la
concentration dans les médias et les
effets qu'elles peuvent avoir sur notre
vie économique en termes de concurrence
mais surtout sur notre vie démocratique
je ne vais pas faire ce que j'ai fait
avec le sucre l'aurait pour mettre en
évidence la raison pour laquelle il
était attendu devant notre commission en
citant pendant six minutes tout ce qu'il
possédait dans le nom d dans le monde
des médias mais
juste parce que moi j'ai mis de
nombreuses heures à essayer de
comprendre tout ce que vous possédiez un
terme de d'entreprises de filiales et de
pays où ils étaient logés et ça c'est
dit voilà à peu près donc ça m'évite des
énumérations de six minutes bien entendu
l'activité média ne fait que je crois 4
% de votre chiffre d'affaires pardon
vous voyez c'est encore plus petits
petits comme on nous l'a dit jusqu'à
présent mais c'est quand même conséquent
parce que vous l'avez dit vous-même il y
a
sfr business pro collectivités
opérateurs et il y à dents avec altis
médias qui est le troisième groupe média
privé français selon votre site même mc
radio rmc story rmc sport s'est
découvert bfm tv biznes région avec tout
ce que vous avez numérique comme le
déploiement local
bfm radio
je vais arrêter puisque j'ai dit que je
ne ferai pas la même mais ce qui est
spécifique on peut arrêter cette
projection
ce qui est spécifique
c'est que
vous êtes présents sur des supports
qui sont
sur toute la chaîne de valeur on va dire
on va appeler ça une concentration
verticale qui n'est pas d'ailleurs
réglementée par la loi de 86 est l'objet
d'ailleurs d'une de nos discussions et
de ce que la apprécié
sur la caducité de cette loi puisque
vous savez qu'on peut posséder deux
métiers de support sur trois est encore
si le troisième la presse ne couvre pas
plus de vingt mille 20 millions de 20%
du territoire et on peut et en plus
si c'est une prennent une presse
d'information quotidienne vous vous êtes
donc posséder les tuyaux comme on dit
voulait fabriquer même vous les posez
vous possédez donc ce qui va acheminer
l'ensemble de cette production de cette
création d'information ou culturelles
vous produisez avec notamment
un ti studio
400 films
régulier de série
par où
vous
vous avez le supporter les fm ex terrain
j'ai cité le support radio rmc et c'est
pas la marge bfm c'est quand même la
première chaîne d'information
en france sur la tnt
rmc bon voilà c'est une radio
conséquente et la presse et libération
et puis l'express le groupe l'express
donc c'est de cela plutôt que
que l'on veut discuter qui et comment
avec des activités que vous déployez
avec succès dans le monde entier avec
une activité donc industriel tout à fait
importante
qu'est ce qu'est ce que la motivation
vous avez même anticiper tout à l'heure
que j'allais vous poser la question
de la motivation de vous impliquer dans
le monde des médias mais au-delà de
cette motivation qu'on peut nous se
demander légitimement
s qu'elle vient servir
vos activités autres l'influent ce que
vous pouvez avoir d'autant que là
il ya un lien avec la commande publique
quand on gagne
la licence sfr et bien je sais que c'est
l'état qui le décide et que
donc il y a un lien quand même avec l'
influence politique possible
est ce que au delà de votre motivation
vous allez nous exposer plus précisément
où daigné ses critiques que l'on
pourrait faire sur vos motivations est
ce que vous pensez st comme citoyen que
dans des démocraties
quel que soit d'ailleurs les motivations
et les
volonté initiale des propriétaires on
puisse
concentrer quand on a une telle
fortune ou telle richesse une telle
puissance industrielle
l'ensemble de la chaîne de la valeur de
la production d'information bien
nécessaire à la démocratie quand elle
peut se faire
à l'abri des influences indépendante
libre diverses voilà ma première
question
alors merci monsieur le sénateur je vais
répondre très précisément votre question
juste quelques petites précisions je
suis pas venu avec mes slide donc vous
avez pris un slide que je pense que vous
avez relevé dans un journal
alors je vais vous dire exactement je
sais lequel c'est oui mais pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de doutes eurent pour que
nos ceux qui nous écoutent l'entente
c'est l'économiste benoit boussemart
octobre 2015
édition est un puits voilà si vous
contestez
alors vous pouvez nous dire ce qui est
contesté mais alors les délocalisations
aussi je comptais sont aussi diverses
que le panama le luxembourg new york la
grande-bretagne
et puis la suisse vous avez oublié la
suisse oui voilà donc la suisse donc
c'est là que j'habite alors d'abord
c'est 2015
effectivement en 2015 j'avais une
holding à guernesey je ne l'est plus
tout mes sociétés sont basées au
luxembourg deuxièmement le tête de mon
groupe était au pyla ne l'est plus
puisque je vous ai commencé la séance en
disant qu'à l'époque j'avais 60 % du
capital de mon entreprise 40% étaient
sur marché effectivement nous étions à
la bourse d'amsterdam
j'avais expliqué lors d'une commission
aux précédentes pourquoi j'étais à la
bourse d'amsterdam est pas la bourse de
paris la chose était relativement simple
la seule raison tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs j'ai croisé un étranger qui
m'a expliqué que ses enfants un étranger
ses enfants nés en france qui pouvait
devenir français ne le sont pas devenus
parce que c'est le papier c'est
tellement compliqué qui préférait rester
danois hebbadj que de prendre les
papiers français donc moi la seule
raison pour laquelle j'ai terminé ma
bourse la société aux pays bas c'est que
c'était plus facile qu'à paris comme les
pays bas ça fait partie de la commission
européenne je pensais pas que c'est un
gros problème donc plusieurs choses qui
ont changé par rapport à cette slide je
n'ai jamais eu une société au panama
donc je sais que tu es en déclarations
entre sermange effet
intenté une démarche que j'ai arrêté
parce que ça sert à rien perdre son
temps
auprès de france télévisions parce que
j'étais numéro un genre et semi public
numéro 1 comme sur les panneaux à people
je n'ai jamais eu d'aussi et au panama
l'abus beau expliquer ça aux
journalistes une fois que le mal est
fait et c'est trop tard c'est publié
tout le monde croit ce qui est publié
même si c'est faux bon ça sert à rien
après 2 du passé son temps à lutter
contre des bêtises qui ne servent à rien
bon voilà première chose deuxième chose
je ne suis plus propriétaire de
l'express
et je ne suis plus propriétaire de
libération et je peux vous expliquer
pourquoi ça prendrait des heures je peux
aussi vous expliquer pourquoi je les ai
achetés je l'avais déjà expliqué c'est
la stricte vérité la raison pour
laquelle j'ai acheté libération c'est
comment moins d'acheter sfr et bien
libération est en dépôt de bilan
et certains parlaient sur france
télévision le soir tard en dit long mais
je vais l'acheter à la barre du tribunal
de commerce j'ai trouvé ça plus propre
de l'acheter directement
alors ça va répondre à une partie de
l'adn questions sur est-ce que c'est
simple des hommes d'affaires ou des
entrepreneurs de certaines fortunes
détiennent des médias ou des titres de
presse moi je pense que c'est
extrêmement sain parce que quand le
capital d'une entreprise est fragmentée
entre plein de personnes qui n'ont pas
les moyens quand tout va bien il n'y a
pas de problème mais quand il ya un vrai
problème économique et industriel quel
point ce qui était le problème de la
presse et qui est toujours là le point
de la presse c'est mieux d'avoir
quelqu'un qui a les moyens de renflouer
un journal que d'avoir dix-huit
l'actionnaire chacun n'ayant pas les
moyens de renflouer le journal et qui ce
qui se dispute du matin au soir donc moi
j'ai sauvé libération
on m'avait dit ça va vous coûter 14
millions ça m'a aussi beaucoup plus que
14 millions de sauver libération et
libération est toujours vivant et on
répondra tout à l'heure pour quoi je
limite dans une fondation si vous voulez
mais cette vague sur une indépendance
totale
j'ai pas sauvé bfm j'ai racheté bfm
parce que je pensais qu effectivement
c'était une bonne affaire qui était en
cohérence avec mes métiers et qui me
permettait de me développer davantage
d'ordre dans le monde rural comme je lé
fais j'ai commencé par cela avec cadel
coquelicot ce qui avait cette cohérence
de développement régional au moment où
vous les fibres et la france et
d'ailleurs on développe dbfm dans toutes
les régions de france alors tout à
l'heure vous parliez est ce que c'est
pour avoir de l'influencé dans la
commande publique excusez-moi de vous
corriger chez les amateurs mais les
licences télécom
ça se discute pas dans le bureau de
ternat d'un homme politique ou d'un os
dents ou d'un homme d'état c'est des
enchères auxquelles vous pourriez
participer d'ailleurs est ce le plus
offrant qui gagne donc ma dernière
licence je les payais 750 millions
d'euros j'aurais pu la payer beaucoup
moins cher si je n'avais pas eu les tard
quand qu'on compte compte en tant que
concurrent puisque l'état est au capital
d'orange
donc ça aurait pu coûter beaucoup moins
cher donc on participe en réalité à la
vie française en investissant non
seulement
dans les infrastructures en payant la
maximum d'impôt puisque sfr ne paient
pas d'impôts puisque pratiquement plus
d'impôts quand je l'aï acheté puisqu'il
était en situation de perdre l'argent je
vous dis paie beaucoup d'impôts et enfin
en payant les licences dont croyez-moi
acheter des médias ça n'a rien à voir
avec une demande d' influence moi je les
30 millions de clients chez sfr j'ai la
moitié de la france donc je parle même
pas je promène dans la rue tout le monde
me connaît enfin de connaître tout le
monde connaît mon entreprise j'ai pas
besoin d'avoir une influence sur quoi
que ce soit à la commande publique
j'ai pas de commande publique aucune
commande publique je pense alors pour
répondre à la question est-ce que c'est
sain
d'intégrer les médias
je crois qu'une des grandes
problématiques
c'est l'avenir économique du métier et
qu'est ce que vous devez ou pas faire
moi j'ai rien à vous dire mais je peux
vous donner mes idées
pour comment faire évoluer le système de
lois dont vous êtes en charge
puisque vous mentionnez la loi de 86
ouais j'avoue fisc et là il était pas né
en 86 on parle d'une loi les gens aux
commandes bientôt ils étaient même pas
nés on pourrait aussi parler de la loi
sur la télévision noir et blanc de 1972
55 les lois sont désuètes par rapport
aux technologies en place aujourd'hui
moi je pense que c'est très sain la
consolidation dans des secteurs
extrêmement fragmenté et très saine pour
l'économie parce que vrai tout à l'heure
je prends un café à paris c'est évident
café-croissant 8 euros un abonnement à
la 5g chez sfr vous pouvez trouver des
abonnements à 8 euros vous passer cinq
heures par jour à votre téléphone vous
prenez un café ça prend 30 secondes
c'est pas forcément très bon pour la
santé
cc c'est délirant c'est à dire c'est pas
logique que le café soit aussi cher et
c'est pas logique la bonne nouvelle à 5
chez soi aussi peut faire on n'a pas de
quoi être fier en tant que français
d'avoir des services d'une telle
l'utilité d'une telle importance brad
est un tel prix alors qu'elle est le
résultat des courses mais le résultat
des courses et que les opérateurs
américains sont ultra puissants ils sont
pas puissants parce qu'ils font de la
politique ils ont dix ans parce qu'ils
font des résultats ils font des
résultats parce qu'ils se sont
concentrés et aujourd'hui le mouvement
sur les médias dans notre industrie ça a
été un mouvement où les opérateurs de
télécoms donc les tuyaux ont essayé
d'intégrer son dévouement qui ont été
faits à plusieurs reprises les médias
j'ai essayé certaines parties j'ai
décidé de continuer certaines parties je
les ai arrêté par sur la presse papier
j'ai décidé d'en sortir puisque le
mécanisme que qui était en place ne
fonctionnait pas correctement par contre
sur la partie
télévisuelle pourquoi on fait de la
fibre optique c'est pas pour échanger
des sms c'est pour faire de la formation
en
interactif vidéos etc en lien direct
avec la télé donc c'est logique d'avoir
les grandes entreprises et donc
indirectement les grands entrepreneurs
qui les détiennent au capital des
entreprises de médias d'ailleurs si vous
regardez le marché américain moi je
connais bien le marché américain puisque
je suis un acteur un petit acteur suis
une entreprise de la taille de sfr mais
je détiens que 2% du marché aux états
unis et bien les grands groupes de
médias américains sont contrôlées par
des personnes physiques et ce avec
google facebook et compagnie sont
contrôlées par des faits sens physique
est ce que c'est bien pour la démocratie
c'est fantastique pourquoi pas ce que ça
donne à tous les jeunes quand la
possibilité et moi j'ai eu la chance je
suis issu d'une famille de profs j'ai eu
la chance grâce au système d'éducation
que j'ai reçu de pouvoir me développer
en france sur me dis demain tu peux plus
rien faire tu peux plus rien acheté
était dans les télécoms qui peut pas
faire des médias était dans l'immédiat
tu peux pas faire des télécoms ou alors
te donner par exemple une anomalie de la
loi de 86 à l'époque on peut comprendre
mais peut-être une chaîne de télé on
passait à trois on avait déjà du vent
dans les cheveux bon on est passé à 250
chaînes de télé u ne s'était pas assez
de 157 euros donc une fois qu'on est à
qu'on dit on ouvre on a privatisé on a
utilisé les deuxième fréquence troisième
fréquence très bien une fois qu'on est à
250 qu'on garde la loi 86 qui par
exemple vous interdit de détenir plus de
49% d'une entreprise qui a une certaine
audience en france c'est complètement
ridicule parce que je sais par exemple
vous allez recevoir monsieur bouygues
qui détient 49% de tf1 est la première
chaîne privée de france est ce que vous
pensez qu'il a plus ou moins d'affluence
en ayant 49% au tampon dont ça change
rien par contre je peux vous dire
qu'avec 40 9% aux etats-unis il se marre
les gars si vous voulez qu'il fasse avec
son entreprise il a aucun moyen de la
développer d'ailleurs il s'est pas
développé en dehors de france parce
qu'elle américains quand ils arrivent en
europe qu'est-ce qui fait il est
propriétaire de son entreprise aux états
unis et avec ces résultats le chinois il
fait pareil d'ailleurs avec ce résultat
il investit à l'étranger
nous les français pour développer à
l'étranger il faut qu'on soit vachement
bon parce que dans les médias déjà dès
qu'on est un peu gros on peut pas avoir
plus que 49%
imaginez moi quand j'ai repris le groupe
bfm on faisait 3% d'audience aujourd'hui
grâce à nos investissements d'augmenter
les effectifs les journalistes et
investissement on est à 7 % me
discipliner passe une certaine audience
n'a pas le droit d'avoir plus que 49%
boxe il faudrait que je revende 51% mais
c'est débile donc tout ces trucs là ça
tient pas la route on suit ensuite quand
on nous dit et d'ailleurs le
rapprochement tf1 m6 ils n'ont pas droit
d'avoir plus de cette chaîne de
télévision ça valait plus de cette
chaîne mais il faut en revanche d'autres
pourquoi cette pourquoi pas 5 pour
groupe à 9 nous ça sort et c'est ça
l'esprit n'a pas que le nombre de gènes
ça devrait être en rapport avec
l'audience est ce que tout risque
concrètement les lois de 86 vous a
empêché de faire eux bien évidemment
l'acquisition d'un bien évidemment je
fais est ce que vous croyez que j'avais
la possibilité d'acheter 49 % des mêmes
six comment on fait pour financer une
supposée médiateurs vont les acheter une
maison vous allez voir votre banquier
c'est à dire là je vais acheter une
maison mais je peux acheter que les
toilettes de la salle d'entrée et la
première semble reste bas mais un gars
51% comment voyez-vous le financer
d'ailleurs le rachat ou le lot le c'est
pas un achat tf1 n'est pas en train de
racheter n 6 et une fusion il vend et le
groupe quick va avoir 35 % le groupe ii
sur alberto nisman
donc c'est des trucs qui empêche le
développement en réalité mais comme quoi
c'est
ce que je vous dis si vous me permettez
monsieur dray
vous exposez votre point de vue mais
j'ai pris près d'une heure comme une
évidence ou comme la seule position
possible lors
même les faits montrent des choses
différentes de ce que vous nous
expliquez vous montrer qu aux états unis
il se développe parce que il n'ya pas de
limites c'est pas vrai c'est depuis
trump qui a plus de limites parce que
sinon où s'il y en a aux étages et avant
qu'on lève toutes les contraintes et
toutes les règles on ne pouvait pas
posséder une grande chaîne de télé et la
presse écrite alors je vais lui c'est
pas comme ça maintenant mais je vois là
je suis sûr que les élus les lois
françaises que moi mais je connais mieux
le marché américain oui alors beaucoup
moins avancés ce n'est pas vrai ce que
je viens de dire écoutez cnl vous savez
qui a fondé cnn ted turner ted turner à
fond d'ici et nazione des détenus par un
groupe de télécoms maintenant donc on ne
dit pas non je viens de j'étais très
précis dans ce crime ont dû peut-être où
est alors je répète jusqu'à jusqu'aux
dernières des réglementations sous
l'impulsion de donald train on ne
pouvait pas posséder d'avoir plusieurs
grandes chaînes et on ne pouvait pas
posséder une grande chaîne de télé est
un organe de presse écrite
lorient donnez moi je dis pourquoi de se
fondre moi j'ai acheté québec-vie jeunes
y avait une chaîne de télé est due à un
journal numéro un dans la région de new
york numéro un dans la presse dans la
télé donc non je suis désolé
josé je pouvais aller chercher leurs
affaires sociales source moi je vais
vous donner des chiffres le groupe vous
avez là trois grandes chaînes aux états
unis les trois sont contrôlées par des
personnes physiques une dames et deux
messieurs je les connais les trois brian
roberts john malone et chez et sharon et
red stone trois personnes physiques et
grâce à sa l'entreprise est stable parce
que une personne physique c'est quoi
c'est passé nous on n'est pas là le
matin quand on va travailler on n'est
pas la dire tiens je vais créer des
emplois où je vais gagner de l'argent
c'est pas ça l'objectif de m honneur
ni dire je vais détruire des emplois où
je vais faire des rues structure a pas
du tout l'objectif d'un entrepreneur
c'est de faire grandir son entreprise
c'est à dire aujourd'hui nous faisons
par exemple 10 francs de chiffre
d'affaires on vous dit comment on va
faire l'année prochaine pour faire on
sera en douce et bien ça peut se faire
par croissance interne ou par
développement par acquisition et donc il
est logique quand on atteint une
certaine taille de regarder à racheter
certains collègues ou certains
concurrents ou certains fournisseurs ou
c'est la logique du monde industriel et
de renforcer les entreprises ça permet
de construire des champions c'est comme
ça non moi j'ai racheté des entreprises
qui étaient qui était pratiquement en
dépôt de bilan on les a restructuré et
grâce à ça eh bien nous sommes
aujourd'hui présente en plein pays du
monde et c'est que ces grands et aux
etats unis nous pouvons faire cela donc
les aussi devons nous voyons on essaie
d'avoir le maximum de questions j'ai
entendu votre point de vue ou au fin
d'audition après que mes collègues vous
auront posé leurs questions j'aurai les
éléments à nouveau pour vous répondre
sur ce que j'ai affirmé que vous
contestez sur les états unis
j'ai une autre question à vous poser
celle la plus plus concrète
que vous avez fait le rachat
des titres du groupe belge roularta 2015
l'expansion l'express lire studio ciné
live mieux vivre votre argent classica
et pianiste cette acquisition sans
dépasser la simple sco sauvera d'un
titre emblématique parce qu'on a eu on a
eu comment dire
notamment par monsieur arnaud
cette explication ou âgées pas d'intérêt
à acheter des titres de presse
en fait je viens comme un mécène
sauveteurs d'entreprises en difficulté
si ces titres peuvent encore exister
c'est grâce à moi bon chacun peut
apprécier 6,6 et les rênes motivation
mais là concrètement
vous avez vous nous avez dit ça pour
libération
vous faites qu'ils y sion
mais ce que je viens de citer montrent
qu' il y avait quand même
une stratégie de votre groupe d'aller
vers la presse et vers la presse écrit
pouvait nous l'expliquer non c'est parce
que j'ai dit que les moines tchador il y
avait une stratégie d'aller dans les
médias télévisuels et j'ai racheté
libération et c'est vrai mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec monsieur
arnaud j'ai sauvé libération je me suis
pas réveillé un matin on tient je mets
dans les journaux sûrement pas j'ai
racheté libération au moment où cette
entreprise avait besoin de 14 millions
pour ne pas passer au dos au tribunal de
commerce contre faillite et moi j'étais
en train de faire un chèque de 14
milliards donc je me fais interviewé sur
l'impulsion près son nom par une
journaliste du du de libération juge de
francs qui viendra vous pourriez pas
nous aider vous allez dépenser 14
milliards nous on a besoin de 14
millions pour finir le trimestre je la
regarde moi je calcule vite vous savez
ça fait 1 pour mille c'est le gars qui
s'achètent chez et par une paire de
chaussures 100 euros il ya un gars dans
la rue qui qui va pas bien il a besoin
de 10 centimes à gizy majorité je vais
voir ce que je regardais le dossier le
soir j'appelle de gaz d'itau mode
dossier et j'ai acheté ça mais j'ai
passé ça pour pour d'autres raisons
alors je les ai sentis moins émouvant je
vais vous en donner une possible vous
avez commercialiser ses titres via le
kiosque sfr en appliquant un taux de tva
de 2 1% avant d'être contraint en 2018
de revenir au taux annuel de 20% et de
subir un redressement en conséquence
sincèrement si vous saviez que vous
serez à 20% est-ce que vous aurez été
sur sétif d'ailleurs depuis vous voulez
délaissé alors déjà désengagé je vous
réponds sous serment et en plus
sincèrement et honnêtement quand j'ai
racheté libération prochaine même pas ce
que j'allais en faire je savais que
j'allais faire par le plaisir à mes
parents parce que mes parents ils sont
profs de maths enfin il était prof de
maths donc vous imaginez pour qui voter
bon donc moi ça leur a fait plaisir
parce qu'ils disent et ils mon fils il
est dans le business il n'a pas réussi
toute la famille soit docteur soit prof
de maths bon ok je rachète ce truc là
pour les non mais c'est la vérité et là
je reçois des sms de copains à patrick
ça nous fait plaisir pour une fois tu
vas perdre de l'argent là ça me vexe
quand on me dit ça tu comment je m'en
sors pas avec libération c'est
impossible de m'en sortir tu vois
comment on fait pour être un peu plus
gros pour faire des synergies et c est
là c'est exactement ce qu'a dit monsieur
arnaud moise le gars de l'express est
pas moi qui l'ait appelé g1 monsieur
belge qui m'appelle allô bonjour
monsieur driss et si la belgique une
fois qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça vous
intéresserait le groupe l'express
l'express pour le coup pour embêter mes
parents moi je lisais l'express elisé
libération sébastien ouais pourquoi pas
ça va compléter le machin et c'est comme
ça que ça s'est passé il faut qu'on
était là dedans on se dit ce truc là
c'est comme on dit une patate chaude qui
s'écroule c'est à dire que chaque année
sa belle c'est légal et gestionnaires
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font que
licencier des gens et chaque année sa
baisse on peut rien y faire demandez aux
jeunes mon fils il n'a jamais touché un
papier réel ça n'existe pas qu'est ce
qu'ils font les jeunes les jeunes lisent
les journaux mais pas ceux là qui sont
au curry lui ils élisent là dessus et
moi je me dis bah tiens ça y est je vais
trouver un modèle économique je vais
mettre plein de journaux ensemble le
plus possible et je vais les diffuser
auprès de mes 15 millions d'abonnés est
là depuis la nuit des temps il y avait
deux régime de tva différents en france
entre les télécoms et les médias puisque
la télévision à péage
c'était je crois cinq et demi pour cent
la tva
et donc c'est effectivement on a profité
du régime en place de la loi en place
donc on a diffusé sa est d'ailleurs le
contrôle fiscal en question je suis pas
le seul à l'avoir parce que tous mes
concurrents - imiter parce que dès qu'il
sait faire a mis son kiosque est
fantastique je peux vous dire ma mère
elle est abonnée aux trucs tous les
profs de france 2 elle est d'ailleurs
pas que chez nous malheureusement ena
qui sont abonnées chez les concurrents
et en bleu c'est la diversité mais en
tout cas là on a appliqué la tva c'était
magnifique et là ça faisait repartir le
truc de le magazine qui est élevé par
mille personnes y avait 15 ans à ma
question est très concrète donc encore
plus parce que du coup on apprend
maintenant quand vous avez été ramenés
on change la loi c'est 20 % aux pays-bas
lors il ya plus d'intérêt on peut plus
diffuser quand tout s'est écroulé moi je
suis pas chez un mécène pendant quelques
jours mais pas pour le restant de ma vie
et donc on s'est lancés débarrasser donc
c'est bien c'est bien ça parce que vous
avez été mis à un
autocar et moins d'intérêt écoutez de
faire le mécène on va dire je vous
explique nommé amorce le mécénat je le
mets c'est un mur entre étant bien que
vous vous avez dit on licencie et c'est
bon quand vous allez prix sfr vous avez
dit on licencie draps presse écrite
cetera vous êtes venu sauver mais
n'est pas complètement connu pour monter
vos affaires et prendre possession de ce
que vous achetez sans des plans sociaux
gigantesque de sfr vient tout cet art
dans toutes les agences il ya une boucle
en 2002 sans licenciement c'est dire
tout le monde peut pas parler en même
temps oui d'accord moi je les écoute les
essaye de poser des questions pas d etat
d donc je donc j'ai levé la main droite
en jurant donc si vous dites des contre
vérités nous est pas très juste moi je
te dirai arrêtez vous des contrevérités
voilà vous n'avez pas licencié e s à
faire mais comment ça fait orange dix
ans si plus que moi jagaille donc
pourquoi vous dites que je ne dis pas
l'avion 10 achètent des entreprises pour
licencier c'est totalement non j'ai pas
pour licencier j'ai dit que quand vous
avez fait des entreprises c'est combla
pour les rentabiliser grands plans de
licenciements c'est que ceux qui sont
licenciés sont des êtres humains et
coiffée comme j'aimerais y avait 800
personnes y en a mais il faudra ici lui
s'il vous plaît bon on va au nord mais
passons on va calmer un peu non oui mais
s'il vous plaît mais sud-rail et les
mois je suis très calme alors ma
dernière gestuelle de ceinture à porter
ma dernière question de cette série
vous voyez bien les inquiétudes que l'on
peut avoir
quand effectivement il y a un
propriétaire
puissant dans le domaine des médias
pourquoi parce que l'indépendance des
rédactions la liberté des journalistes
est quelque chose qu'il faut préserver
et donc on dit on peut se demander si
il peut y avoir des interventions sur
cette liberté éditoriale et de travail
journalistique donc
un communiqué commun des sociétés des
journalistes de rédaction de bfm
business bfmtv comme bfm tv et rmc c'est
élus
de la situation suivante c'est la
décision de mettre fin à la
collaboration d'un journaliste du
magasin du magazine capital sur
l'antenne bfm business grégory raymond
qui participait régulièrement à
l'émission bfm bourse en tant que
spécialiste de la future monnaie s'est
vu signifier la fin de ses interventions
en raison des choix éditoriaux de
capital la direction du groupe a mis en
avant des articles jugés malveillants
envers altis sfr et leurs dirigeants
pour justifier cette décision
unilatérale la fin de cette
collaboration n'a aucun lien avec le
travail de grégory raymond dont la
qualité des interventions a toujours été
saluée ne peut-être que dommageable à
l'antenne bfm business signé des sdj
c'est des sociétés de journalistes de
bfm business de bfmtv com de bfmtv de mc
qui tiennent à l'indépendance des
rédactions et reste particulièrement
vigilant sur les interventions d'altis
sfr à leurs actionnaires dans le contenu
éditorial donc là ils disent que c'est
l'intervention de l'actionnaire qui a
conduit à la fin de cette collaboration
que répondez vous écouter alors moi je
vois beaucoup de choses dans la presse
qui sont pas exacts je peux vous dire en
tant que c'est pareil ces lenteurs
laissé répondre monsieur dry parce que
sinon on va avancer il ya de nombreuses
d'intérêt cette société de rédaction de
vos réactions la question est formulée
on va laisser répondre d'abord je crois
qu'il est monsieur raymond jamais
entendu parler de ma vie
ensuite
je vois beaucoup de choses dans la
presse qui sont fausses
j'ai vu des choses me concernant qui
étaient fausses c'est pas pour l'instant
c'est pas pour le monde pour autant que
je réagis parce que franchement ça me
laisse de marbre bon et puis si on
devait réagir à tout ce qui était faux
je pense que j'aurais pu casser le passé
de 24 heures pour répondre par exemple
tout à l'heure la première diapositives
étaient fausses nous je vous ai pas
interrompu ce vous a laissé parler une
balise était faux c'était faux il y
avait des erreurs elle était plus date
et donc vous avez sorti un document qui
est factuellement faux sur plein
d'égards
deuxièmement ce que vous venez de
raconter c'est une société de
journalistes donc c'est comme ce sont
des journalistes c'est leur version peut
demander au directeur général de sfr de
bfm pardon ce qui s'est passé dans
l'occurrence je ne sais même pas de
combat voilà c'est ma réponse je peux
pas vous en dire plus en tout cas moi je
ne suis pas interdit que cette opération
si ces tablettes élections oui je vous
dis je ne suis pas intervenu sur cette
opération et je n'interviens pas sur le
contenu la seule chose qui m'intéresse
vous savez sur quoi j'interviens
c'est sur les performances financières
économiques de l'entreprise et la vision
de développement notre entreprise c'est
à dire que ce qu'est ce que je fais
quand j'arrive sur bfm c'est une le
groupe 1 bfm rmc qui s'appelle
nextradiotv c'est une entreprise quand
je leur achète qui fait 190 millions de
chiffre d'affaires et moi je dis
voilà comment on va faire pour faire de
la croissance à tout ce que j'ai dit n'a
pas marché aujourd'hui la même
entreprise la même entreprise fait 340
millions de chiffre d'affaires juste et
je suis un bon résultat moi je suis
content je continue maintenant de savoir
ce que dit tel ou tel joueur n'a aucun
impact sur ce que je viens de vous dire
et donc on n'est pas la regarder ce qui
est dit ou ce qui n'est pas dit et c'est
pas pour ça qu'on fait ça on fait ça
vraiment comme développement économique
d'une belle entreprise voilà mais sud
rail
nombreuses questions qui enfin nous re
sénateurs et sénatrices nouvelle vous
poser des questions j'ai d'abord
commencé par an pose et une pour bien
préciser parce que vous avez fait
référence plusieurs fois à libération
moi j'ai deux questions sur libération
d'abord ou qu'elle la situation
financière de libération actuellement et
puis deuxièmement alors vous n'êtes plus
effectivement propriétaire directement
de libération puisque vous l'avez cédé à
un fonds de dotation en 2020
ma question est toute simple mais qui
est derrière ce fonds de dotation si ce
n'est vous et est ce que vous pourriez
nous éclairer sur le lait les financeurs
du fonds de dotation alors effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est moi mais vous serez
tous les bienvenus c'est un fan qui est
ouvert vous pouvez le financer chacun à
hauteur de vos moyens demain matin vous
serez les bienvenus d'ailleurs parce que
ça l'aiderait la facture de fin d'année
quelle est la situation financière je la
connais pas l'entreprise libération est
totalement indépendante j'ai doter ce
fonds d'un capital d'une vingtaine de
millions d'une trentaine de millions à
un moment donné quand j'ai transfert
quand gère quand je rachète libération
en
2015 pour être précis je crois le
closing ces faits 2015 l'entreprise
perdait à peu près 16 millions par an
donc j'ai dû renflouer à hauteur d'une
centaine de millions libération parce
qu'on est passé de -16 à -12 de -12 à
mon avis et c'est quand j'ai mis
libération dans le fonds pour assurer
son indépendance
et justement ne plus vous faire régler
mais je voulais revenir sur la partie
excusez moi mais c'est là c'est très
important de comprendre l'esprit d'un
entrepreneur j'en suis qu'un seul mais
je pense qu'on partage parmi les
entrepreneurs un peu les mêmes valeurs
parce qu'une fois qu'on est à la tête
d'une entreprise
qu'on a fondée s'est uni c'est
l'histoire d'une vie c'est quoi et c'est
spécifique aux français ça les
américains ne peuvent pas le faire nous
on pense que nos enfants ils vont
continuer c'est notre rêve en tout cas
on aimerait que nos enfants et continue
mon fils de prof est vrai que les
enfants et parents et white choix propre
moi j'suis pas propre et j'aimerais que
mes enfants ils sont entrepreneurs bon
on se dit je peux pas laisser à mes
enfants un truc qui perd de l'argent à
vie parce que lui ici les pas
philanthrope mais il va tout arrêter et
donc les trucs qui perd de l'argent
c'est me les mettre dans les espèces
d'organisations philanthropiques qui
attire des subventions ou des ou des
donations pas des subventions des
donations donc c'est pour ça et c'est au
gmi et alors pour répondre à votre
question quelle est la situation un
ancien aujourd'hui je la connais pas
mais je pense que le journal perd un peu
d'argent beaucoup moins qu'à l'époque y
perdre et comme je voulais 17 à 18
millions il doit perdre deux ou trois
millions
excusez-moi part de votre juste pour
finir j'ai mis dans la structure du
fonds 20 millions de cash en plus quelle
est la centaine que nous avions dépensé
j'ai mis 20 millions de cash pour faire
suite pour faire pour pourvoir aux
besoins des peaux des prochaines années
c'est un sujet qui nous intéresse
beaucoup bien sûr l'équilibré économique
des médias juste pour revenir sur ce
système de fonds de dotation dont on
perçoit qu'il se développe de plus en
plus est-ce que vous avez bénéficié de
la défiscalisation
quand vous avez investi 20 millions dans
le fonds de dotation non papa sur ces 20
millions mais par contre je vous la vous
la dot à cela la mise en fondation
d'inde journal vous permet alors je
connais pas les détails techniques mais
vous permet de défiscaliser une partie
des arbres de l'argent perdu mais c'est
un peu comme l'ailé les rues ce qu'on
appelle les reports déficitaires dans
les entreprises mais je connais pas la
technique exact moi est ce que je
voulais c'est sortir de sfr puisque en
fin de compte libération est une filiale
de sfr et sait faire et est reparti en
croissance libération était on va dire
légèrement décroissance quand je l'aï
racheté hyper des hits only descendez 10
15% par an donc il était à plus ou moins
1% on l'a confié à des professionnels
c'est géré par quelqu'un qui est
complètement indépendant moi je ne lui
parle alors là pour le coup jamais je
regarde même plus la situation
économique c'est plus mon problème et
lui est libre de lever de l'argent
auprès de n'importe qui si demain
libération de gan dollar alors j'en
profite pas s'il en perd c'est pas mon
problème et c'est à lui maintenant est
allée à l'équipe de rédaction des décidé
de de l'heure de leur futur économique
rédactionnelle et ainsi de suite comme
d'ailleurs avant sur la partie
rédactionnelle ça n'a jamais changé
j'aurais m'engueuler
merci président bonsoir monsieur draghi
depuis le début de cette commission
denquête en ce qui me concerne j'aurais
deux questions et petits propos
liminaire près courbet depuis le début
de cette commission denquête nous voyons
défiler si vous me permettez
l'expression des grands capitaines
d'industrie
des entrepreneurs qui sont tous touchent
pas un pas d'une exception à la règle
tous venus nous dire
avec leur leurs mots leur personnalité
la même chose exactement la même chose
qui est plutôt rassurant quand on
connaît un petit peu l'économie ce qui
n'est pas en france et notamment
l'éducation à l'économie vous en avez
parlé tout à l'heure ce qui n'est pas
vrai on a une marge de progression on va
dire pour être positif ils sont tous
venus nous dire des vérités têtu c'est à
dire que pour avoir des emplois il faut
des entrepreneurs s'il n'ya pas
d'entrepreneurs qui entreprennent n'y a
pas d'emploi ils sont tous venus nous
dire aussi que
avant d'être grands ils ont été petit
et que aujourd'hui le business que ce
soit celui de l'audiovisuel d'autres il
est tournée forcément vers
l'international et à ce moment là dans
la compétition on s'aperçoit que souvent
dans notre pays on a tendance à vouloir
faire courir le 100 m aux entrepreneurs
avec un boulet au pied ils sont tous
aussi venu nous expliquer qu'il faut une
vraie volonté d'entreprendre que
derrière la réussite il ya une
intelligence stratégique et puis aussi à
un moment donné il ya un risque
financier le plus calculer possible avec
des montages qui peuvent paraître des
fois je vais employer ce mot là
alambiquée mais qui sont forcément
validé et qui in fine et si
l'intelligence stratégique a fonctionné
mettre dans le mille avant même de
parler de classement forbes alors si on
analyse vos investissements votre
trajectoire vous l'avez dit depuis 2016
il ya eu il ya eu un parcours et vous
êtes assez visionnaire qu'il s'agisse de
concentration verticale voire même
diagonale vous êtes un expert
alors mes deux questions sont les
suivantes pensez vous que l'acquisition
de diffuseur mais aussi le contenu est
désormais indispensable à l'activité
d'opérateur de télécommunications
et la seconde pensez vous pour envisager
le champ publicitaire concurrentiel
pensez vous qu'il faut considérer les
plateformes comme de nouveaux éditeurs
de télévision
monsieur le sénateur pour votre analyse
je pense pas qu'il soit indispensable
une entreprise télécom d'être dans les
médias c'est ce qu'on a cru dans les
années 2014 suite à une grande vague de
rapprochements entre les télécoms et les
médias outre-mer
est ce que j'ai un peu essayé de suivre
d'ailleurs quand je rachète les droits
de
de l'apcm plus qu'on appelle à tuer le
championnat de football européen très
cher suite à un appel d'offres européen
j'essaie de copier à l'époque le modèle
de nos amis british telecom qui avait
acheté le championnat de football
anglais bon ça s'est pas passé comme je
le pensais on fait parfois des erreurs
et je suis toujours j'ai tout alors on a
développé rmc sport grâce à cela cela
j'ai toujours rmc sport mais j'ai revu
mes investissements parce que
l'entrepreneur c'est c'est un être
humain tend parfois il fait excuser moi
des bêtises pour pas dire un mot un peu
plus gros des fois des grosses bêtises
bon on en fait tous par contre on
s'adapte parce que si on en fait trop
longtemps qu'on n'est plus là bon pour
moi j'ai revu un peu ma stratégie sur le
sport pourquoi parce que le sport le
problème si vous contrôlez pas votre
destin complètement
il peut y avoir des groupes qui
débarquent du jour au lendemain qui
participe à des appels d'offres mondiaux
et qui payent des prix qui sont
déraisonnables par rapport à la réalité
du marché et c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs sur le marché français et ces
sports et ses sports l'apparence et ses
entreprises ce sont des entreprises qui
dans leur pays ont moins de contrainte
parce qu'ils peuvent être beaucoup plus
gros
donc je pense que c'est pas
indispensable dans l'est dans les médias
pas du tout aujourd'hui je pense
néanmoins qu'il est intéressant d'en
garder certains qui se développe
nous avons changé par exemple la radio
j'avais rmc dont on parle moins que bfm
mais c'est une radio importante en
france ça doit être la deuxième ou
troisième radio privée derrière le la
télé villars à la radio nationale
c'était une
c'est une industrie en éclats
[Musique]